i'll now introduce you to the concept of
the laplace transform
and this is truly one of the most
useful concepts that you'll learn not
just in differential equations but
really in mathematics and especially if
you're going to go into engineering
you'll find that laplace transform
besides helping you solve differential
equations
also helps you
transform
functions or or waveforms from the time
domain to the frequency domain and and
study and understand a whole set of
phenomena but i won't get into all of
that yet now i'll just teach you what it
is laplace
transform
i'll teach you what it is make you
comfortable with the mathematics of it
and then in a couple of videos from now
we'll i'll actually show you how it is
useful to uh to use it to solve
differential equations we'll actually
solve some of the differential equations
we used we did before using the previous
methods but we'll keep doing it and
it'll solve more and more difficult
problems so what is the laplace
transform well the laplace transform of
the
the the notation is
the l like laverne from laverne and
shirley
might be before many of your times but
i grew up on that
so actually i think it was even reruns
when i was a kid maybe well anyway so
laplace transform of some function and
here the convention instead of saying f
x people say f of t and the reason is is
because in a lot of the differential
equations or a lot of engineering you
actually are converting from a function
of time to a function of frequency and
don't worry about that right now if it
if it if it confuses you but the laplace
transform of a function of t
it transforms that function into some
other function of s and how does it do
that well actually let me just
let me just do some mathematical
notation that probably won't mean much
to you
so what is a transform well the way i
think of it is kind of a function of
functions right a function will take
what will take you from one set of well
in what we've been dealing with one set
of numbers to another set of numbers
a transform will take you from one set
of functions to another set of functions
let me just define this the laplace
transform
for our purposes is defined as
the improper integral i know i haven't
actually done improper integrals just
yet but i'll explain them in a few
seconds the improper integral from 0
to infinity
of e
to the minus
s t
times
f of t so whatever is between the
laplace transform brackets
d
t
now that might seem very daunting to you
and very confusing but i'll now do a
couple of examples
so what is the laplace transform well
let's say that f of t is equal to one so
what is the laplace transform of one
the laplace transform of one so if f of
t is equal to one
it's just a constant function of time
well that will be equal to
and let me rewrite well actually let me
just substitute exactly the way i wrote
it here so that's the improper integral
from 0 to infinity
of e to the minus st
e to the minus st times 1 here well i
don't have to rewrite it here but
there's a times 1
dt
and i know that that's probably that
infinity is probably bugging you right
now but we'll deal with that shortly
actually let's deal with that right now
this is the same thing
this is the same thing as the limit
and let's say
let's say as a approaches
infinity as a approaches infinity of the
integral from zero
to a
e to the minus s t
d t
so this is
just so you feel a little bit more
comfortable with it you might have
guessed that this is the same thing
because obviously you can't evaluate
infinity but you can take the limit as
something approaches infinity
so anyway let's take the anti-derivative
and evaluate this improper definite
integral or this improper integral so
what's the antiderivative of e to the
minus st with respect to dt
well it's equal to
what minus 1 over s
e to the minus st right if you don't
believe me take the derivative of this
you take minus s times that that would
all cancel out and you just be left with
e to the minus st fair enough and we're
going to take actually let me delete
let me delete this here
this equal sign because i could actually
use some of that real estate
we are going to take
the limit
as a approaches infinity you don't
always have to do this but this is the
first time we're dealing with improper
integral so i figured it might as well
remind you that we're taking a limit
and we're going to evaluate we took the
anti-derivative now we have to evaluate
it at a
minus the anti-derivative evaluated at 0
and then take the limit of whatever that
ends up being as a approaches infinity
so this is equal to
the limit
as a
approaches
infinity
of okay if we substitute a in here first
we get
minus 1 over s remember we're dealing
with t the the
the we took the integral with respect to
t
e
to the minus
s
a
right that's what happens when i put a
in here
minus now what happens if when i put t
equals zero in here
so when t equals zero it becomes e to
the minus s times zero this whole thing
becomes one and i'm just left with minus
one over s so i had minus
minus 1 over s
fair enough and then let me scroll down
a little bit i wrote a little bit bigger
than i wanted to but that's okay so this
is going to be the limit
as a approaches
infinity
of
minus 1 over s e to the minus s
a
minus minus 1 over s so plus
1 over s
so what's the limit as a approaches
infinity well what's this term going to
do
as e approac as a approaches infinity
the exponent is going to get if we
assume that s is greater than zero and
we'll make that assumption for now let's
actually let me write that down
explicitly let's assume that s
is greater than zero so if we assume
that s is greater than zero then as a
approaches infinity what's going to
happen
well this term is going to go to zero
right e to the minus
a google is a very very small number and
a e to the minus google plex is a very
even smaller number
so then this e to the minus infinity is
approaches 0. so this term approaches 0.
this term isn't affected because it has
no a in it so we're just left with
over s so there you go this is a
significant moment in your life you have
just been exposed to your first laplace
transform
eventually and i'll show you in a few
videos there are whole tables of laplace
transforms and eventually we'll prove
all of them
but for now we'll just work through some
of the more basic ones but this can be
our first entry in our laplace transform
table that the laplace transform
the laplace transform of
f of t is equal to one
is equal to
one over s notice we went from a
function of t although obviously this
one wasn't really dependent on t to a
function of s
i have about three minutes left but i
don't think that's enough time to do
another laplace transform so i will save
that for the next video see you soon